good boy Sava only place only place a
local boy asagai Oh anyplace good boys
ups a local boys
good boy I asked the guy that's the guy
around here good boy here that's the guy
good boy good boy acid like good boys
all right Sabo boy Sabo yes have a quick
command here come in here quick Sabo
come here quick Sabo chicken chicken
come on here yeah
yes sir but quick come here come here
come around here quick
well you just lost that Salva clean up
up up up up up up sit up saddle good boy
sit up asagai sit up all right good boys
good boys Ali Sabbah quick hey let's
have a quick and over sample quick
Alex I'm a baker I'll a saddle quick
over sample quick
good boy Sabo good boy any place or any
place a but quick Savo up here quick
here
Sabo quick here good boy yeah good boy
Sabo good boy asagai sit down come boy
sit down sit down sit down sit down good
boy good boy
okay Sabo good boy
Sabo i late have a quick la-style pick a
lace have a good boy
Sawa a quick at least I'm a good boy Hey
ladies have Oh
Sabo a quick hello a quick add a salve a
quick
Sabo and a quick good boy over good boy
good boy only place on your place quick
right Sabo Sabo come here quick yeah
come here boy here he is have a good boy
here yes have a good boy here now lay
down good boy Sabo always a good boy
good boy good boy Sabo who's a good boy
good boy good boy good boy
man all right only place quick all right
so any place any place I have a Greek on
you place a brick Sava quick up Sabo
come here quick up here
saddle up here quick Sabo hey later
quick add a salve a quick
are they Sabo yeah yeah come here come
up here quick up here why good boy sit
down sit down sit down
good boy asagai good boy
oh boy Szabo come here Szabo come here
quick yeah come over here
sobbing here quick oh boy here now lay
down good boy here this have a quick now
go boy Raoul Raoul quick roll it's
having a quick roll we also have a quick
roll also have a quick roll yeah let's
have a quick roll roll you know come on
out here boy
that's it roll roll roll roll roll roll
good boy Tsavo good boy yeah he's bitten
the end of that good boy
okay now good boy sit up sit ups have a
big good boy sit up sit up sit up sit up
saddle quick sit up sit up sit up Saavik
oh boy oh boy lay down lay down go boys
have oh good boy
always a good boy good boy now all right
Tony place all right so any place quick
only place a but quick a funny place
only place good boy here so have a come
here quick yeah Sal come here quick here
come here now sit down sit down sit down
sit down sit down sit down sit down sit
down the boys do I asked the guy well
boy yes ah but quick give me a sound oh
boy here boy
sit down sit down have a kiss
go boy Sava to the boy to the funds to
the funds always a good boy good boy
good boy good boy Java boys have oh good
boy good boy ask the guy that's a guy
good boys now all right so any place
thick
all right Sonia place only place it's
our bond your place quick Sabo come here
tab over here come here come here come
here little boy sit down good boy sit
down okay this okay stay there stay
there good boy stay there stay there
stay there all rights go boys